Narrator: In "Jurassic
Park"'s famous kitchen scene,
this shot featured a man
in a full raptor suit.
While the raptors in this
shot were created digitally.
These shots featured raptor puppets
and actors wearing
raptor boots and gloves.
You know that great moment
where the raptor reaches in,
opens the door?
That's just a guy wearing a raptor glove
and reaching around.
Narrator: The "Jurassic" movies
have constantly innovated
how dinosaurs appear on-screen,
pushing CGI forward
while never exclusively
relying on digital methods, even in 2022.
We spoke with nine of the minds
behind the "Jurassic"
creatures to find out
how dinosaur effects have evolved
over the course of three decades.
Steven Spielberg first
envisioned his dinosaurs
as entirely stop-motion creations
designed by legendary stop-motion
animator Phil Tippett.
How'd you do this?
I'll show you.
They didn't want to initially trust
that we could do full-CG T. rexes,
because he was the most
important critter in there.
All the other ones could kind of
wander around in the background,
but as far as the actors acting to that,
that was the big one.
So we got the test shot
that we showed to Steven,
and that's what changed the film.
Narrator: Jean was there for
one of these initial tests.
Jean: Suddenly, you went
from things that were
like a skeleton or the
Mercury Man in "T2,"
you went to something that had color
and texture and a sheen to it.
You could put anything anywhere
on the screen and make it alive.
Narrator: The only problem:
It looked like the manpower
needed on the computer-animation
side would be too high.
So the stop-motion
artists at Tippett Studios
worked with the VFX team at ILM
to develop dinosaur
input devices, or DIDs,
physical models of the dinosaurs
hooked up to computers.
The skeletons were covered with sensors
that tracked the
orientations of their joints
and sent that information to the computer,
translating the movement into key frames.
Traditional stop-motion
animators could then work
with the computer models without having
to master computer-animation software,
shifting their skills
to the digital realm.
Phil: That was the
thing that really melted
the glacial divide between
traditional stop motion
and computer graphics.
Narrator: Thanks to CG,
"Jurassic Park"'s T. rex
could go from being a background character
to a star of the film.
Spielberg even rewrote the
ending to include this fight
between the CG T. rex and two raptors.
The real secret to the
dinosaur's believability, though?
When we first meet the T.
Rex, in the paddock sequence,
it is a combination of
CG and practical effects.
Narrator: Designed by
FX pioneer Stan Winston
and his team of sculptors,
puppeteers, and mechanics.
Matt: That sequence cuts
between both methodologies.
If you intercut CG with an actual,
physical on-set puppet,
they're never quite sure
what they're looking at.
That is the reason that
that remains, to this day,
one of the more realistic fantasy
moments in cinema history.
Narrator: The animatronic dinosaurs
had their own advancements.
Matt: The dinosaurs of "Jurassic Park"
required a whole rethink
on the mold-making process.
Traditionally in practical effects,
it would be done with
various types of stones.
These would not be appropriate materials
for gigantic molds.
So the studio looked to the epoxies
that were being used in
the aerospace industry
and applied those materials
for the dinosaurs.
It allowed them to create very large,
very durable molds that
would retain their integrity.
They wouldn't warp.
Narrator: Like these
raptor puppets seen in
the attack on Muldoon.
Matt: I was actually the
raptor left-arm puppeteer
in most sequences. The
arm cable-actuated devices
allowed for fantastic
expressiveness with their hands.
Narrator: And for the iconic,
complex kitchen sequence?
Matt: That sequence involves
every possible trick
in the book to make you
believe raptors are real.
CGI raptors, insert
puppets that were basically
the head and a bit of the neck,
lower-body rigs that were just the legs,
raptor gloves.
It includes men in raptor
suits when they first
enter the kitchen and one
of them rears up and hoots.
[raptor calls]
That's a man in a suit.
The men-in-suit approach
was great for wider shots like that.
But when you're close up,
more often than not, it will be a puppet.
Narrator: Ultimately,
there were 15 minutes
of dinosaurs in "Jurassic Park."
Matt: Nine minutes are practical puppets;
six minutes are CGI.
Stan was a huge believer
that the best way to fool an audience
is don't lean too
heavily on one technique.
Keep them guessing.
Narrator: By the time the
second "Jurassic" movie
rolled around, practical
innovations meant the team
could lean even more on animatronics.
Matt: On "JP II," they changed it up.
They wanted the skins to
move more realistically,
and so they created an elaborate network
of foam musculature.
And on top of those
foam muscles that moved
and intersected very realistically,
they laid a much thinner skin,
so that you could actually get a sense
of the musculature moving
underneath the skin.
Narrator: Plus, Stan Winston's mechanics
extended their use of hydraulic motors
used on the T. rex in the first movie.
Matt: Even though the Tyrannosaurus rex
from "Jurassic Park I" was by far
the toughest character to pull off,
it actually was the easiest to puppeteer,
because it was a hydraulic puppet
puppeteered via a telemetry device,
so it only took a few people
to puppeteer that big T. rex.
So that technique was what
we used for every dinosaur
in "Jurassic Park II," other
than the smallest of them.
And thanks to that approach, the raptors,
which in the first one took 18 of us
at times to operate, only
took two or three people
to operate in "Jurassic Park II."
Narrator: The smallest
dinosaurs still relied
on more traditional puppetry,
like the Compsognathus, or "compies,"
chicken-sized dinosaurs
that attack in packs,
most notably when they
team up to kill the hunter.
Dennis: There were so many
of them, and so many CG ones
had to jump on this actor.
And they all had to be performing,
and the guy's moving
like this and thrashing,
and he's pulling them, and all the weights
when they jump onto this
moving guy had to be right.
Narrator: Stan Winston's team
built several types of puppets
to perform a range of compy behaviors.
One type of puppet attached to the actor
via Velcro pads on a hidden suit.
Superstrong fishing line
rigged the puppet up
to an off-screen controller,
which a puppeteer could tug
on to create a pecking motion.
Meanwhile, an airline
trigger ran air through
the compy's tail, causing it
to whip around in a frenzy.
For this shot of Stormare
trying to grab and pull
the compies off, the team used a puppet
with high-powered magnets on its feet.
These magnets attached to other magnets
sewn into the actor's clothes,
making the compy difficult to pull off.
The puppeteers could also
be as close to the puppets
as needed, since they could
just be erased in post.
The length of the puppeteering rods
before digital had to be really long.
But if you can't get close to the puppets,
you can't really do much
in terms of controlling it.
It's always going to have
this kind of bouncing,
kind of floaty kind of quality.
Now, with digital, you
can choke up on that rod.
You can be just a couple
inches from the puppet,
and you can be moving it
around really smoothly.
The prime example is the
sequence where the little girl
and the compy interact there on the beach.
The puppeteers were right there.
They were within just a
foot or two of that compy.
Narrator: In the final shots,
the team mixed puppet
compies with digital ones,
which you can spot based on movement.
Mainly the ones that seem
to have a lot of pizzazz
and a lot of anger, I
think, are the ones that we
could animate enough to
make them look interesting.
Narrator: These mini
dinosaurs set the stage
for a much larger creature
in "Jurassic III,"
which would demand the heaviest, biggest,
and fastest dinosaur robot ever built.
Joe: We wanted a dinosaur
that could defeat T. rex.
You know, T. rex is
everybody's favorite dinosaur.
Narrator: The movie's
paleontology consultant,
Jack Horner, suggested the Spinosaurus,
which was bigger and more vicious,
capable of killing the T.
rex in the final showdown.
The foundation of that final
showdown was practical,
filmed with two massive animatronics,
as demonstrated here in
an early hand-puppet test.
But filmmakers couldn't have
the two puppets really go at it.
They would've destroyed
each other pretty quickly.
Narrator: So they storyboarded a fight
that used an animatronic Spinosaurus
and a digital T. Rex in some shots,
and vice versa in others.
Joe: That, I think, was the first time
in "Jurassic Park" movies that they were
actually interacting with
each other physically.
Narrator: For the
animatronics, the crew took
one of the T. rexes
from the previous movie
out of storage and
refurbished it for the fight.
But the Spinosaurus had
to be built from scratch.
Matt: The audience had to believe
that this dinosaur could kill a T. rex.
So it had to be bigger,
it had to be faster.
The T. rex had about 200
horsepower driving it.
The Spinosaurus had 1,000 horsepower.
It was five times more powerful.
It was far sturdier
than the T. rex as well,
which had actually been quite delicate.
Narrator: Once the
final Spinosaurus design
got a thumbs-up from a
consulting paleontologist,
the team sculpted an 8-foot-long,
one-fifth-scale maquette.
Instead of sculpting the
animatronic from clay,
like they did for the T. rex,
the crew went with a
more high-tech method.
They used a cyberscan of the maquette
to create computer-milled foam pieces.
And all these pieces had to withstand
a very specific element:
water.
Cut! Good, good.
Matt: In "Jurassic Park I," the T. rex
was rained upon extensively.
The foam skins acted like a sponge
and absorbed tons of water in every shot,
which affected its performance
because it was finely
tuned to a certain weight,
but when all the water was absorbed,
it changed all those calculations.
They waterproofed the T.
rexes in "Jurassic Park II"
with a layer of silicone
over the foam skin.
And that waterproofing approach
reached its pinnacle with the Spinosaurus.
Which, the inner mechanical devices
were waterproofed in waterproof housings.
Aspects of the Spinosaurus'
face were actually cast
in a solid urethane that
would not absorb water.
That, to this day, remains
the Guinness Book of World Records
largest animatronic ever built for a film.
Narrator: It was so large, it
had to be lifted with cranes
and driven to Universal Studios on a route
that didn't go under bridges.
Once on set, the crew mounted it
to a motorized cart that ran on tracks,
which allowed the animatronic
to move forward and backward
while it moved up and down on cylinders.
And to get those fast
movements you see here,
the Spinosaurus used
state-of-the-art hot-rod hydraulics
controlled by an 18-inch telemetry device.
William H. Macy, who played
Paul Kirby in the film,
said the puppet could turn its head
at twice the force of gravity,
with the tip of its nose
moving at 100 miles per hour.
Its strength didn't make
it indestructible, though.
Joe: That scene with the airplane,
every take, it would
lose one of its claws.
Every take was a, "All
right, go back to the shop."
Narrator: When filming the big fight,
the two teams of puppeteers
used their telemetry devices
to swing the puppets around.
Joe: That took about 12
animatronic operators
to do each one of them.
Narrator: Although they tried
to keep physical contact
between the two puppets to a minimum,
the T. rex still got hurt.
Joe: It was actually
before the fight started.
It was the two animatronic
dinosaurs sort of roaring
at each other, T. rex sort
of started going crazy.
The puppet was just sort of vibrating,
and it turns out that one
of the hydraulic lines
had broken inside and hydraulic
fluid was going everywhere.
And re-skin part of it and try to
sew it back together and everything.
It was wild. It's on film somewhere.
Narrator: 14 years
later, major improvements
in performance capture
made complex movement
like this possible in the
second "Jurassic" franchise,
a step up from puppets and stop motion.
"Jurassic World" sought
to bring its velociraptors
to a whole new level of realism,
giving them an unprecedented
complexity of motion.
It was difficult for a
performance-capture artist
to physically stand the way that a raptor
is supposed to for a
prolonged period of time.
And velociraptors do have a unique size
and shape compared to human performers.
But ILM was able to retarget
the captured performances
of the human actors to the raptor bodies
without losing the subtlety
of the performances.
The reward was that the raptors look heavy
and lifelike with very
intricate movement on-screen.
With CG having advanced to this level,
the next film could go beyond pure realism
to give life to a genetically
engineered dinosaur
that never actually
existed: the Indoraptor.
Unsurprisingly, this massive dinosaur
would mainly be a digital creation.
But the actors needed
something to react to on set.
Neal: There was a lot
of physical interaction
between the actors and the
dinosaurs in "Fallen Kingdom,"
more so maybe than in the previous films.
Narrator: The solution, for some scenes,
came in the form of partial animatronics,
like this giant mechanical arm
and a moving, breathing head
operated by a team of puppeteers,
who controlled the tiny
movements in the eyes.
Neal: A good deal of the Indoraptor
was performed using a
real-time animatronic.
Narrator: The crew also
built a nonmoving head.
Neal: We created a full-size Indoraptor
head and neck and tail that was made
from a very lightweight
inflatable material,
so we actually blew it up
like a child's bouncy castle,
made a rig for it to allow
two performers to wear,
one the front end and one the back end.
We would use these inflatable versions
in any scene where the
actors needed an eyeline
or visual effects needed
a scale representation
that wouldn't be in the frame.
Narrator: These various
forms of the Indoraptor
not only provided the cast
with tangible scene partners,
they also gave the camera
team something physical
to work with and the VFX team a reference
for the Indo's lighting and movement.
Neal: The movement of the
Indoraptor seemed to me
to be quite faithfully followed.
I'm never really quite sure
whether there was a paint
overlay or whether or not
there is a complete scene
substitution for the
Indoraptor in the end.
I find it very difficult
to know where and when
the technique begins. It's great.
Narrator: On "Jurassic World: Dominion,"
decades of innovation made it possible
to create hybrid dinosaurs
that were part-CG,
part-puppet, like the Giganotosaurus,
a dinosaur with a head the size of a car.
The head, roughly just
above the shoulders,
was an animatronic, and the
rest of the creature is digital.
And if you can see where it's slightly
more opaque white around
the head and the neck,
that's the physical piece of the dinosaur
that was going to be
made as an animatronic.
We needed to be able to keep it
and extend the rest of the
dinosaur in postproduction.
And so it was really
important that it moved
in the same way as our digital creature.
So this is the range of motion
in the physical animatronic
sufficient to allow the dinosaur
to do what it needs to do.
We could actually pass that
information back to John Nolan,
who was the creature effects supervisor.
So when John was making the animatronics,
they would be positioned in such a way
that matched ILM digital models.
So it's kind of digital creatures
driving practical animation.
Narrator: To reflect
paleontological research,
the digital team also developed tools
to create feathered dinosaurs.
David: Feathers has been
a long-burning desire,
I think, for all of the "Jurassic" fans.
Feathers are really
complicated to simulate
and to describe all of that
very intricate geometry in 3D.
So we actually built a
brand-new feather system at ILM
in Houdini that we've
dubbed internally Quill.
So we were able to build
this procedural system
which gave the artist the
control over the groom
and the texturing of those feathers
that allowed simulation with snow, wind,
water, all in the same software package.
Narrator: Even with new
feathered creatures,
the dinosaurs created
by Stan Winston and ILM
nearly three decades ago are
still seen in today's movies.
For "Jurassic World: Dominion,"
director Colin Trevorrow
wanted the VFX creatures to feel as close
as possible to its predecessors.
So the digital team conducted
what they called digital archeology.
David: The T. rex is where this
digital archeology comes in.
We actually went back into
the ILM digital archives
from the original "Jurassic Park,"
and we restored the original
3D Softimage models.
So we were able to make sure that the
model we're using from
"Jurassic World: Dominion"
matched as closely as possible.
And at the same time,
we actually went back
to Stan Winston's original
physical animatronic.
And we have loads of really amazing
reference photography of it,
and we completely retextured
the T. rex to match it.
Narrator: CG has come
a long way since then.
ILM only had 60 shots in "Jurassic."
Now we'll do several
thousand shots in a movie.
We are aware that these
walked the face of the Earth.
And for that, they have a
very, very special place.
And it also makes it
that much more exciting,
because you're kind of, you know,
"Wow, I'm bringing something
to life, a real thing to life."